إذا مشيت هناك وجلست بجانب السيد.
جونسون وحمل هاتفي ، هل
يعلم Google أنني كنت جالسًا هنا ثم
انتقلت إلى هناك ،
فأنت مرحب بك في أي وقت قاضي نعم أو
لا ، لا أعرف بصدق دون
معرفة الصدمات التي لا أعرف هل تفعلها أو
لا أجمع المعرفات  مثل الاسم
والعمر والعنوان نعم أو لا إذا كنت تنشئ
حسابًا هنا ، نعم وتستخدم حسابًا ،
نعم سجلات بحث محددة عندما
يكتب الشخص شيئًا ما في البحث أكثر
إذا كان لديك سجل البحث قيد التشغيل نعم
معرفات الجهاز مثل عنوان IP أو
أنا هو  اعتمادًا على الموقف الذي
يمكن أن نجمعه ، نعم ، إشارات GPS ، إشارات
Wi-Fi ، إشارات Wi-Fi ،
سيعتمد ذلك على التفاصيل ، لذلك قد تكون هناك
مواقف نعم GPS نعم ، إذا كان
لديك إجبار على المحادثات عند استخدام
منتجات Google Voice ، فإننا نعطي خيارًا
لتحويل  في كثير من الأحيان ، إذا كان الشخص
لا يعرف ما هو الصوت في المحادثات
عند استخدام منتجات Google Voice ،
فإنك تسجل فقط عندما بدأ مع
Okay Google ثم تذكر المصطلحات بعد
محتويات رسائل البريد الإلكتروني و  في مستندات Google ،
نقوم بتخزين البيانات ولكننا لا
نقرأ أو ننظر إلى Gmail الخاص بك ، فلديك
حق الوصول إليها كشركة لدينا
حق الوصول إليها ، لذا يمكنك القول
إنك لا تعرف أنني لا أطلب منك ذلك أو
لا  أنا أقول أنه يمكنك على الرغم من
وجود احتمال أن يكون لدينا
سياسات ثابتة واضحة حول كيفية قيامه
بهذه البيانات ، وقد تم تغيير سياسات الخصوصية الخاصة بهم التي
تتحدث عن ذلك 28 مرة
بما في ذلك ثماني مرات منذ يناير 2016 ،
لذلك أعتقد أن السياسات التي تعرفها و
هذا هو السبب في أنني أطرح هذه الأسئلة ،
فهناك العديد من الأشياء التي أخذناها ولا
نجمعها ، على سبيل المثال لا نجمع ،
يمكن أن يكون لديك منتج مثل google home ،
ولن تقوم بجمع المحادثات ما
لم تطلب منا تحديدًا لذلك تسأل
سؤال ولذا فنحن بالتأكيد حريصون للغاية ونعمل على
تقليل البيانات التي نحتاجها
لتقديم الخدمة مرة أخرى إلى مستخدمينا ،
فلماذا تحتاج Google أولاً إلى كل هذه
المعلومات يمكننا الإجابة على ذلك في
حقيقة أن 85476 بالمائة من أرباحك
تأتي من الإعلانات  نحن نعرف ذ
تتلاعب بالبيانات في بعض الطرق ، ومع ذلك ،
هل يمكنك شرح ما تفعله لتقليل
هذه البيانات التي تكون عمومًا
باستثناء ممارسته المعتادة بين أولئك
الذين يجمعون البيانات التي تعرف أن هدفنا هو
أنك تعرف ولكننا نقدم على
سبيل المثال إذا كنا نقدم لك
خدمة  مثل Gmail الذي قمنا به
لمدة 15 عامًا ، تلك البيانات التي نحتاج إلى
تخزينها لمستخدمينا حتى يتوقعوا منا ذلك ، لذلك
نحاول جاهدين مطابقة توقعات المستخدمين ،
ولا نحتاج إلى معرفة
بياناتنا للإعلان كما قلت سابقًا في
معظم الأحيان  إنها تأتي من الكلمات الرئيسية
التي تكتبها فقط ، ولذا فأنت تعلم أننا بحاجة إلى الحد الأدنى من
البيانات للقيام بالإعلانات ، فنحن نقدم لك
خيارات لإيقاف تخصيص الإعلانات ،
لقد سرقنا معظم البيانات التي نقوم بها اليوم
للمساعدة في منح المستخدمين التجربة التي
يريدونها وهذا ما نطمح إليه "  إعادة تحاول القيام به